ah
muy buenas tardes a todos ustedes
bienvenidos al programa de capacitación
de khan academy mi nombre es pedro
aparicio y eso es un verdadero gusto el
poder estar con ustedes el día de hoy
daremos inicio a esta capacitación del
módulo 1
para el ciclo escolar 2018 2019
este día tocaremos varios temas en
nuestra agenda empezando por lo que es
carne de mí
en quienes somos sobre el programa de
capacitación
empezaremos a trabajar con su cuenta de
canacar de mí lo hablaremos también
sobre mejoras prácticas de
implementación algo que es increíble que
es el campeonato para el regreso a
clases 2018 2019 hablaremos un poquito
sobre la mentalidad de crecimiento y los
siguientes pasos para su certificación
khan academy y quienes somos gracias
gracias por venir ya tenemos a mucha
gente en el chat si tienen algún
problema técnico o algún comentario
favor de escribir sus comentarios en el
chat
ya tenemos gente como jesús cortez de un
largo cartagena
[Música]
mate clips o carlos el mango y el de
escalante entre otros gracias por
acompañarnos esta tarde
estamos aquí para apoyarte con el
objetivo de maximizar los resultados
académicos de todos tus alumnos
si te encuentras frente a tu laptop
puedes abrir una pestaña nueva e
ingresar la siguiente liga
https dos puntos
dos guiones
o punto g l diagonal p g
mayúscula t
d
mayúscula d
les daría un par de minutos para que
puedan copiar esta dirección electrónica
en el buscador inclusive le pueden tomar
una fotografía con su celular para que
tengan a la mano esta presentación de
inclusiva y la pueden revisar más tarde
nos acompaña a gerardo ocasión desde
mérida yucatán
[Música]
están haciendo el comentario que tienen
problemas con el audio asegúrense de que
tienen
el volumen adecuado pueden subir
teléfono inteligente laptop o
computadora
ok estoy dando un poquito más de tiempo
para que puedan tener la presentación a
la mano
inclusive pueden darle clic en una
estrellita de favorito para que la
tengan guardada permanentemente en su
computadora
jose castillo nos dice que ya nos
escucha perfectamente desde saltillo
coahuila bienvenido a este webinar de
khan academy gracias por acompañarnos a
esta tarde
bueno las tardes norma martínez
dolor es javier presente conalep y coman
bienvenidos a cada uno de ustedes
un verdadero gusto
el hablar sobre el programa de
capacitación por parte de canacar de mí
una excelente herramienta que los puede
acompañar
en sus clases de matemáticas o ciencias
quienes somos
somos carne min una educación gratuita
de clase mundial para todos
en cualquier lugar y en cualquier
momento en un ambiente 24/7 24 horas los
7 días de la semana
somos una organización sin fines de
lucro tenemos la fundación carlos slim
bien en el fin de gates foundation
tenemos también a
el patrocinio de google y más
patrocinadores alrededor del mundo
nuestro fundador es salman khan
él quien hizo el lanzamiento del sitio
en español desde el 2013 todos los
contenidos todas las materias
completamente en español la sede se
encuentra en silicon valley california
tenemos materias de matemáticas ciencias
programación entre otras
khan academy es una experiencia de
aprendizaje interactiva que se convierte
en el mejor aliado del profesor ya que
le permite ahorrar tiempo asignado
haciendo ejercicios y prácticas
personalizadas en cada uno de sus
estudiantes
nuestra plataforma es gratuita divertida
y está disponible las 24 horas del día
nos dedicamos a reducir las barreras
para lograr el acceso global a la
educación en pleno siglo 21 es de vital
importancia que nuestros estudiantes
tengan acceso a una verdadera calidad de
la educación sin ningún límite sin
ninguna barrera
es por eso que nuestra plataforma está
completamente en español
para poder erradicar esa barrera del
idioma muy bien
si ustedes tienen
como servicio de internet tel cel
por medio de la fundación de carlos slim
cuando usted es entre la plataforma de
khan academy no podrán nos gastarán sus
datos en su teléfono inteligente lo
único que tiene que hacer es accesar
desde
el buscador escribiendo es puntos 0.1
punto org y tendrán acceso a todo el
material académico las materias y el
seguimiento de sus estudiantes sin tener
problemas de conectividad esta es una
excelente noticia para todos los
usuarios de telcel en mexico
les presento alejandro es un estudiante
de bachillerato que nos da su testimonio
sobre el uso de esta herramienta de khan
academy sobre esta plataforma
y sigue hacia adelante para que yo no
tengo que vivir lo que ha vivido
[Música]
lo que sí muchísimos medios pueden
matemática acción de un casino son muy
buenos
esta plataforma no lo hace de una manera
es demasiado
excelente testimonio de alejandro tienen
comentarios sobre el vídeo favor de
dirigirse al chat
[Música]
por medio de la plataforma de chan
academy estamos hablando de una práctica
personalizada
para diferentes materias y grados
escolares con más de 10.000 ejercicios
vídeos y artículos
matemáticas para todos los años
escolares química física computación y
mucho mucho más
y al día de hoy estamos ofreciendo un
programa de certificación totalmente
gratuita
y el día de hoy estamos aquí para hablar
de nuestro programa de capacitación para
este nuevo ciclo escolar
es por eso que el día de hoy estamos
pidiéndole a todos los profesores de
mexico unirte a esta comunidad comunidad
de docentes inspiradores para crear
para desarrollar habilidades en nuestros
estudiantes
khan academy te invita a convertirte en
un experto en el uso de nuestra
plataforma
[Música]
puedes participar
en tres módulos de capacitación
por cada módulo recibirás un certificado
que acreditará como un experto en el uso
de canicas de mí
contarás con todas las herramientas para
implementar con éxito el uso de nuestra
plataforma en tu salón de clases
este programa de capacitación tiene tres
módulos el día de hoy estamos
iniciando con el módulo 1
el módulo 2 se llevará a mediados de
agosto y principios de septiembre y el
módulo 3 se llevará a finales de octubre
en noviembre y estaremos terminando en
diciembre son aproximadamente 6 meses y
en este primer módulo de el primero de
agosto
hablará hablaremos sobre los primeros
pasos
de la plataforma mecánica de mi
llevaremos a cabo la de acción para este
nuevo ciclo escolar implementación de
las mejores prácticas algunas
estrategias bastante bastante
interesantes hablaremos sobre los
lineamientos
para que puedas conocer la plataforma a
fondo
las nuevas características de esta
plataforma de khan academy y hablaremos
un poco sobre la mentalidad de
crecimiento
sobre el enfoque enfoque pedagógico que
puedes llevar a cabo en el módulo 2
estaremos hablando del campeonato
ahora discutiremos qué es y cómo
comenzar hoy les daré un poco sobre
sobre este gran reto de todos los
profesores y estudiantes que él
[Música]
por tantas
me gusta participar
y algo muy importante como motivar a tus
alumnos durante este gran reto cómo
reconocer los logros de tus alumnos
durante el campeonato lo que debo hacer
para ser reconocido como un maestro
campeón como en poder invitar a otros
docentes a que se unan a este reto y
hacer toda una comunidad
entrelazando los
trabajando de manera colaborativa
trabajando en equipo
y así tener mejores resultados
si tienen algún problema con la página
con la plataforma en este caso con el
webinar pueden darle en refrescar
para que es la página se vuelva a cargar
y no pueda tener algún problema técnico
por favor
cuáles son los requerimientos para
obtener tu primer certificado bien pues
ya ustedes acaban de dar un paso
importante
qué es participar en este webinar el día
de hoy
crear una clase que es lo siguiente que
vamos a hacer
asignar contenido y luego completar una
tarea asignada
de esta manera te darás acreedor a tu
1er
certificado del módulo número 1
y precisamente cada cada me está para
eso para dar reconocimiento por tu
trabajo por su esfuerzo por tu
dedicación
para estarte capacitando a ser un
profesor de vanguardia en el siglo 21 es
importante hablar de certificación
aquí se dirá el número de horas que
estás
utilizado para la capacitación de khan
academy que puedes también unirte a una
comunidad de docentes innovadores y por
supuesto recibir apoyo de especialistas
del equipo de khan academy en mexico
nos estaban pidiendo rómulo castillo que
si podemos repasar un poco para los
docentes que se están integrando ahorita
al webinar
esta capacitación este programa de
capacitación consta de tres módulos el
día de hoy solamente llevaremos a cabo
el módulo número 1
que consta con participar en el webinar
de esta tarde el 1º de agosto crear una
clase de métodos nerviosos no pasa nada
ahorita le de todos lo haremos juntos
asignar contenido a esa clase virtual
que estaremos creando y completar una
tarea asignada
el objetivo principal de nuestra
plataforma es incrementar el aprendizaje
de los estudiantes
y al mismo tiempo darle reconocimiento a
su esfuerzo a su dedicación a su tiempo
a los profesores con ustedes que están
comprometidos con mejorar la educación
en cada uno de sus aulas con cada uno de
sus estudiantes y nosotros cada década
me les vamos a dar un reconocimiento
certificado por esas horas de
capacitación
y el primer paso
para este programa de capacitación es
llenar un formulario con tu correo
electrónico
para recibir reconocimiento por tu
esfuerzo y para tener toda la
información necesaria del programa que
consta de seis meses
este documento con la información del
programa vamos a ir añadiendo contenido
e información clave a esta vida durante
un programa de seis meses
en un momento les proporcionará un par
de minutos para que puedan acceder a
estas ligas que les estamos mostrando
ahorita para que puedas crear una cuenta
también está una liga para soporte
técnico inclusive está
la cuenta de un correo electrónico para
que nos puedas enviar todos estos nudos
con todas tus preguntas
pueden tomarle una foto a esta
diapositiva y tenerla a la mano es toda
la información que necesitas
para acceder a este programa de
capacitación
grato bautista nos dice que ya tiene
acceso al documento
serafín reyes nos manda saludos ángel y
que ibarra como saber sin registro fue
exitoso
nosotros tenemos acceso al formulario
que están llenando el registro y les
estaremos mandando un correo electrónico
para que ustedes estén 100% seguros de
que están inscritos a nuestro programa
de capacitación
desde su teléfono inteligente desde su
tableta o desde su laptop pueden tener
acceso a este registro
pueden abrir una ventana nueva y
escribir https dos puntos diagonal
diagonal
punto gl diagonal y mayúscula q
mayúscula o hi5 o mayúscula
y le dan enter
y tienen acceso al registro
voy a dar un par de minutos nuevamente
para que se registren y tengamos toda la
información todos los datos de su correo
electrónico desde donde nos acompañan y
darle seguimiento a este programa de
capacitación totalmente gratuito
normalmente le recuerdo khan academy es
una organización sin fines de lucro
todos los contenidos están en español
y en esta plataforma tendrán acceso
el material a vídeos artículos sobre
matemáticas y ciencias y por qué no
también a clases de programación
una plataforma
totalmente en español
que promueve habilidades digitales
para que nuestros estudiantes estén
preparados a un mundo cada día más
globalizado
si algunos de ustedes tienen problemas
con la conectividad
y les gustaría ver este vídeo también
les enviaremos la liga para que lo
puedan volver a ver
el webinar hoy no sirve atender el
programa
y puedan ser el registro
de acuerdo a su tiempo y de acuerdo a su
conveniencia
i
reciban un cordial saludo en la gente
que nos acompaña desde el norte de la
republica desde tijuana tamaulipas nuevo
león
así como toda la gente que nos acompaña
desde el sureste
del país
[Música]
con el uso de la tecnología podemos
tener exceso
las cientos
quizás miles de profesores desde
educación básica hasta nivel
bachillerato
[Música]
nos comenta jesús cortez que hoy en su
plantearle generaron dos clases para sus
alumnos del nuevo ingreso
excelentes noticias jesús cortez
a todos los profesores que ya iniciaron
clases a nuestro nuevo ciclo escolar
pueden crear las clases que sean
necesarias pueden ser 25 clases las
clases que sean necesarias si eres un
profesor que imparte dos o tres materias
no tienes ningún problema puedes crear
el número de clases que sean necesarias
recuerden son clases virtuales que
puedes darle seguimiento a sus
estudiantes
y ver los registros que ellos mismos van
elaborando
y si todavía no tienes las listas de
estudiantes para este nuevo ciclo
escolar no te preocupes nosotros
está rebosando toda la asesoría para que
el 20 de agosto al 25 de agosto
registras tus clases ya con el número de
estudiantes
y poderte poder darte toda la asesoría
técnica para que tengas tu código y tus
estudiantes se puedan registrar en tus
clases de física química matemáticas no
hay ningún problema
tal vez
a poco
d
para las personas que ya pudieron
ingresar
y darse de alta en nuestra plataforma
tenemos el programa de capacitación que
les comentaba consta de tres módulos el
día de hoy es el primer módulo
con esta dirección electrónica g
punto g l de penal y mayúscula r8
mayúscula jota mayúscula z y s tendrás
acceso a todo el programa de
capacitación que dura seis meses
si tienes tú
celular a la mano puedes tomarle una
foto a esta dirección y así poder
ingresar las veces que sea necesaria a
este programa de capacitación donde
encontrarás el documento con las ligas
con la información pertinente para que
puedas crear una clase con tu material
contuvo con tus recursos con tu temario
y así poderlo compartir con toda tu
clase de una manera virtual
los comentarios pineda que tendrán de
los grupos pero aún no han podido
registrar
para sus estudiantes
y dice que lo hará de inmediato cuando
tenga las listas de
sus nuevos grupos un excelente muy bien
nos comenta elizabeth cortez que ya se
registró bienvenida al instale está
nuestra plataforma
[Música]
nos pregunta román antonio que si es
necesario registrarse si ya se había
registrado el día de ayer no es
necesario con una sola vez que quede
registrado nosotros ya tenemos tu correo
electrónico y daremos seguimiento a tu
labor que lleves a cabo con nosotros en
khan academy
a las flores nos dice que ya está más
que lista con su registro excelente
bienvenida
a todas esas personas a todos los
profesores maestros maestros que ya
están registradas favor de accesar al
programa de capacitación con esta liga
que en esta diapositiva puede tomar una
foto escribir la hoja
de papel
saludos para amanecer la solidez de la
cruz está dada de alta y que está más
que lista
[Música]
luis delfín mendoza nos pregunta que si
es para las ciencias
y para las matemáticas
parece ser que ya está creado una clase
excelente
todos podemos tener acceso a crear una
clase virtual desde la plataforma en que
an academy lo único que tienes que hacer
es
tomar un pequeño riesgo invertir un poco
de tiempo y la plataforma te lleva de la
mano es una plataforma amigable muy
sencilla de utilizar no necesitas ser
ingeniero en sistemas o ser programador
para poder tener acceso a esta
plataforma
no simple y sencillamente escribiendo
esta dirección electrónica el url y
tendrás acceso a todo el programa de
capacitación con un par de clics podrás
crear tu primera clase virtual
vamos a continuar con la agenda
ah
jesús manuel rosete castillo no te
preocupes por el testimonio de alejandro
y podremos enviar las ligas
correspondientes directamente en tu
correo
y también estaremos agregando la
dirección electrónica directamente a
esta presentación
no
vamos a crear una cuenta ya configurar
sus clases
en una pestaña nueva en favor de
escribir ese punto khan academy punto
org
y darle enter y de esta manera te
llevará directo directamente a crear una
cuenta en que demy
favor de escribir ese punto k h y n a c
a d y e mail
y punto r
al darle clic
encontraras esta información
llegarás directamente a nuestra
plataforma de que acerca de mí
favor dar click donde dice maestros
inician aquí
es importante mencionar que este tipo de
plataformas los puedes
lo puedes compartir con tus profesores
de tu escuela de tu plantel
obviamente los estudiantes demandan
tener acceso a esa clase virtual pero
también los padres de familia
pueden dar seguimiento al nivel de
matemáticas de trigonometría de
geometría de sus hijos
si ya tienes una cuenta no es necesario
crear una nueva para tener acceso
a una nueva clase
no me gusta les hablamos avellano del
conalep torreón dice que ya hicieron
clases desde hace dos semanas
perfecto estás más que lista para crear
un par de clases
lo único que tienes que hacer es
registrarte con tu cuenta de gmail
con tu correo electrónico o inclusive
con
la red social de facebook
por supuesto regístrate como un profesor
dos preguntas gerardo cachón ya tengo
usando la plataforma desde hace más de
un año puedo seguir con la misma cuenta
la respuesta es sí por supuesto que
puede seguir utilizando tu misma fuente
de hecho debes seguir utilizando tu
mismo en cuenta no es necesario crear
una nueva
nos pregunta víctor jiménez puedo crear
una clase aunque no tenga alumnos sin
victorias y partes dos materias puedes
crear dos materias y otra vez y hasta
estar tengas tu lista de estudiantes y
empieces a dar sus primeras clases pues
ya solamente les comparte el código que
te va a proporcionar la misma plataforma
una vez que ya te registraste con tu
correo electrónico
la plataforma te está pidiendo darle el
nombre de la clase
el primer semestre de la maestra laura
rodríguez
quinto de primaria del profesor pedro
aparicio
segundo año de secundaria de la maestra
cristina como ustedes
deseen darle el nombre a su clase
inclusive pueden ponerle de la mejor
clase de matemáticas del mundo
ya depende de su creatividad de su
imaginación para darle el nombre de la
clase correspondiente a sus estudiantes
ya que tiene el nombre
en tu clase pues es importante
agregaron
una materia puede ser el sexto de
primaria
3º de secundaria de esta manera la
plataforma de carrera de mí te estará
facilitando los temarios
correspondiente al grado escolar
inclusive si das la materia de biología
química física o ingeniería eléctrica
o temas mucho más específicos como son
trigonometría cálculo diferencial
estadística geometría básica álgebra
preservara aritmética o matemáticas
elementales
y
buenas tardes ismael a la vez
nos comenta ya insertada que tiene
una cuenta desde hace cuatro años y
trabajan de santa fe bienvenida
buenas tardes
me da gusto escuchar que ya hay mucha
gente que utiliza la plataforma
eso significa
que tienen ya ha avanzado el programa de
capacitación están acreditando el módulo
1 y podrán
orgullosamente decir que tienen que
están certificados por khan academy
nile escalando nos nos preguntó que si
puedes guardar el código de su clase o
si por supuesto que lo puedes guardar
una misma plataforma lo recordará tengas
acceso a él
al tablero de control
y si tienes 23 clases hasta 5 clases ya
ser profesores de secundaria de
bachilleratos que puedan aprender así
como hasta 10 clases por supuesto puedes
tener los códigos de 10 clases sin
ningún problema
ya nada más depende del profesor como
esté organizado a su día y tener acceso
a su plataforma
serafín rey nos comenta que ya está
listo solamente espera tener el nombre
de sus estudiantes excelente muy bien
elizabeth cortez nos pregunta cuántos
temas puedo agregar
depende de
del temario del currículum el cual tenga
más para tu ciclo escolar o tu semestre
podrías inclusive ir agregando los temas
pues por bimestre como gustes como
mejor te puedas acomodar
pero no hay un límite de temas puedes
poner los que gustes
bien como les decía aquí tienes el
código
que cada comité va a proporcionar y una
vez que tengas ese código y una vez que
tengas tus listas de asistencia pues
podrás en tu primera clase en tu primera
semana proporcionar no a tus estudiantes
y automáticamente ellos se agregarán la
clase virtual que tú has creado
también puedes invitar a invitar puedes
hacer una invitación por medio del
correo electrónico
y no hay ningún problema ya estarás del
otro lado
y la clase creada ahí podrás encontrar
ejercicios vídeos y artículos para tu
clase dependiendo del grado escolar las
características de tu grupo de tu
plantea de otra escuela asignarlos a tus
estudiantes
ver la página de tu clase para dar
seguimiento al avance de tus estudiantes
de cada uno de tus estudiantes o ya sea
de tu grupo o completo
nos manda saludos maría de la luz rojas
de con alentó
tea calco
aún no tengo
horario puedo practicar con algún tema
de matemáticas por supuesto por supuesto
inclusive si alguno de ustedes tiene
hijos y quiere empezar a hacer prácticas
con tus hijos con tus sobrinos con tus
vecinos
puedes crear una clase y antes de que
termine las vacaciones pues practicar
las veces que gusten las veces que sean
necesarios recuerden
es una plataforma totalmente gratuita
y puedes crear las clases que gustes
continuando con la agenda tenemos las
mejores prácticas de implementación
qué necesidades podrían cantar de mí
cubrir en mi clase
bueno pues depende del potencial del
docente de la creatividad del maestro
para utilizarlo de diferente manera
el modelo número 1 es una práctica
alineada a una lección por ejemplo
profesores de bachillerato tienen su
temario
está muy alineado al programa de la
secta y ustedes pueden darle seguimiento
a ese temario en su clase tener una
práctica guiada para todo el grupo o una
práctica independiente y esto pues lo
pueden hacer dos a tres veces por semana
durante 20 minutos
insisto depende mucho del docente cómo
va a abordar sus temas en clase y cómo
lo puede cómo el estudiante lo puede
complementar en casa
[Música]
pero este modelo número 1 lo que
recomendamos es de dos a tres veces por
semana durante 20 minutos
el modelo 2 es utilizar canal académico
como repaso
y este repaso se puede llevar en el
plantel en la escuela pueden llevar a
sus estudiantes al laboratorio de
computación y aquí lo que recomendamos
es dos a tres veces por mes durante todo
el tiempo de la clase y aquí es
exclusivamente la revisión de una unidad
de un contenido de un tema en particular
modelo 3 que pueden utilizar khan
academy para la tarea
es decir fuera de la escuela pero pues
el tema explicado en clases y aquí va a
determinar al maestro con qué frecuencia
puede dejar esa tarea puede ser una para
la semana una tarea de khan académica
dos semanas depende del docente
y tenemos un modelo 4 la práctica
individual para aquellos alumnos que se
sienten un poco rezagados que les cuesta
trabajo a las matemáticas por ejemplo
bueno a él se le puede asignar un
[Música]
unos vídeos un artículo unos ejercicios
específicamente para ese estudiante y
puede ser tanto en clase o fuera de la
clase con estos ejercicios extras y la
frecuencia pues lo va a terminar
la maestra o el maestro
les comento que para mí el modelo 2 y el
modelo 3 son mis favoritos
me encanta dejar ejercicios de repaso el
canaca de mí o dejarles una tarea a la
semana para que utilizan la plataforma
planeación
ustedes como docentes saben que es
fundamental un plan estratégico para que
no lo sabor que el tiempo y no anden
corriendo antes de los exámenes
[Música]
y nosotros
y les pedimos que puedan elegir al menos
tres recursos cada semana para asignar a
sus estudiantes en sus clases
una vez que ya tengan sus estudiantes
sus clases listas
pueden hacer equipo con otros profesores
del mismo curso recuerden el trabajo
colaborativo es fundamental en pleno
siglo 21 ya no es
hay que salir de ese enfoque
tradicionalista trabajando solo no ahora
hay que trabajar habilidades de
comunicación de colaboración de
pensamiento crítico y de creatividad con
otros docentes del mismo grado
y un profesor se puede enfocar en el
contenido y otro profesor se puede
enfocar en el contenido de repaso a la
evaluación por ejemplo
también pueden crear tareas y revisarlas
para dar retroalimentación
a cada uno de sus estudiantes ya sea de
manera individual o ya sea de manera
grupal
nos comenta sara ferrer que él utiliza
la plataforma para reforzar temas
específicos excelentes muy bien serafín
nos preguntaban y aranda cuál es la
fecha que se debe de asignar la clase a
la clase creada
recuerden que nosotros estaremos
enviándoles un correo electrónico
a lo largo de estas primeras dos semanas
de agosto pero hay tiempo suficiente
para cumplir con esa con esa tarea
[Música]
no se vayan a mover no voy a tener miedo
de cometer alguno
algún error en esta plataforma no va
asignada a la plataforma es tan amigable
que te darás cuenta que siempre que
accedes a esta plataforma
será cada vez más eficiente más creativo
con tus clases virtuales
y si tienes algún problema técnico
necesitas soporte técnico
nos puedes enviar un correo y nosotros
encantados
de apoyarte de orientarte para que todo
esto sea un verdadero éxito con tus
estudiantes
nuestro objetivo es incrementar el
aprendizaje de los alumnos esa es la
otra finalidad
[Música]
ahora que ya tienes una clase virtual
pues tienes que desarrollar un plan para
enganchar el motivar a tus alumnos
romper
esas prácticas tradicionales desechar
las e innovar en tus alumnos se sientan
motivados que su autoestima esté por las
nubes y lleguen con ganas con felicidad
de tomar clases contigo que su
aprendizaje sea significativo
igual ya estaremos del otro lado
no
como podrás desarrollar ese plan
estratégico bueno pues hay que
plantearnos estas preguntas
[Música]
como planear seguir el progreso de tus
alumnos como
piensa celebrar sus logros como puedes
motivar para que tus alumnos sigan
siendo perseverantes y sean alumnos
excelentes
como base valora el desempeño y esfuerzo
de tus alumnos en khan academy todas
estas preguntas te dará una pauta para
seguir para desarrollar un plan
estratégico con tus estudiantes
es por eso khan academy está
comprometido en llevar a cabo un reto
denominado campeón apto para este
regreso a clases del 2018
es un programa gratuito de 10 semanas
para impulsar el aprendizaje en este
regreso a clases al combinar actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento y práctica
de materias en khan academy la clase
entera aumenta su confianza y su
motivación
cuando se llevará a cabo este campeonato
las inscripciones se abren el 13 de
agosto de este año el reto comienza el
10 de septiembre y termina el 16 de
noviembre
alguna algunos de ustedes se preguntarán
es necesario que lleve a cabo estas diez
semanas
y la respuesta es
que este reto se puede acomodar a sus
necesidades y a sus tiempos si solamente
pueden participar cuatro semanas más que
bienvenidos para nosotros lo importante
es que tomen el reto y así sean las
hermanas dos hermanas cinco semanas que
mejor que sean las diez hermanos pero
nosotros estamos conscientes de los
tiempos de las exigencias de cada una de
sus escuelas
dónde se va a llevar a cabo pues
en nuestra plataforma de khan academy
cualquier estudiante de la republica
mexicana de primaria hasta bachillerato
puede participar
el campeonato está pensado para motivar
los estudiantes sin importar su nivel
académico ni su nivel socioeconómico
aquí está
e invitados todos los alumnos de
guerreros de michoacán de oaxaca de
puebla de querétaro de monterrey todos
serán bienvenidos
el programa se adapta fácilmente a todo
tipo de aula horario o ambiente escolar
puede ser todo lo matutino vespertino
inclusive de turno nocturno no importa
la hora
víctor fernández nos comenta que ya creó
su clase y está más que listo para
agregar a sus alumnos cuando tenga la
lista
martín muñiz nos comenta en mi caso
también doy un
en mi caso también doy un porcentaje de
las tareas del canal académico para
motivarlos y puedan reforzar temas
el plantel zihuatanejo
amar lo sabrías saludos saludos a mis
paisanos martín que los acompañó desde
zihuatanejo guerrero excelente
excelente que puedas evaluar a tus
alumnos
dándole un porcentaje a las tareas de
khan academy te felicito y te mando un
saludo fraterno
nosotros tenemos principios de este reto
en primer lugar que es para todos
todos los estudiantes y profesores que
participen podrán inspirar confianza y
motivar el aprendizaje para todos
sin importar su nivel académico con su
nivel socioeconómico promueve una
mentalidad de crecimiento aunque tengan
fallas o fracasos lo verán como una
oportunidad para aprender algo nuevo
para no rendirse para ser perseverantes
este tipo de retos empodera a los
maestros es fácil de implementar en una
variedad de aulas y ambientes escolares
es flexible los profesores saben
mejor cómo motivarlos
y esto permite hacer del profesor un
verdadero héroe
y luego digo que te va a hacer falta es
ponerte una capa y te convertirás en un
héroe
es justo porque pues porque todos sin
importar su entorno escolar tienen la
oportunidad de participar
es muy equitativo es un programa
detallado con reglas fáciles de entender
y temas fáciles de encontrar
ahora él es muy divertido celebra el
progreso del individuo y de la clase con
premios digitales insignias digitales
integra elementos sorpresas y monumentos
de festejo yo creo que esto es algo que
nos hace falta de nuestras aulas
que el aprendizaje sea algo divertido
puedas romper con la monotonía
que se imparte en una materia esto puede
ser para que hagas algo diferente
en el aula de clases conducido para
dejar una tarea una tarea diferente con
la plataforma de khan academy
a continuación podremos ver un vídeo en
donde estudiantes de brasil festejan su
progreso a nivel grupal
la verdad
[Aplausos]
de estos estudiantes de brasil al haber
alcanzado el reto en haber alcanzado su
objetivo dependiendo de su nivel
académico
pueden hacer sus comentarios en el chat
aparentemente estamos tenemos problemas
técnicos porque se está trabando el
vídeo
de refrescar en la página para que
puedan tener acceso al vídeo
parece ser que ese trabajo
no se preocupen le estaremos enviando la
liga para que puedan verlo con calma
igual y depende del número de asistentes
que tenemos en línea
el favor de refrescar su página para que
puedan tener acceso al vídeo a las
personas acceder se tragó nuevamente una
disculpa
nos comentan a gerardo bautista se ve
que el docente realizó muy bien el
trabajo de involucrar a los alumnos y
motivarlos bien dicho gerardo bautista
es nuestro rol como maestros en motivar
el tener enganchados a nuestros alumnos
para que puedan hacer sus tareas y
conseguir todos los retos que nosotros
les vayamos poniendo
quien puede participar en este
campeonato profesores y alumnos de
primaria hasta bachillerato de cualquier
escuela incorporada a la secta en la
república mexicana
el campeonato combina miles de
ejercicios gratuitos de khan academy con
incentivos de edición limitadas para
motivar celebrar y premiar el esfuerzo
de cada estudiante sin importar su nivel
ah
[Música]
actualicen su página por si tienen algún
problema técnico algún plan de
conectividad o de la misma plataforma
una disculpa por favor
o
[Música]
por qué
una maestra del conalep maestra de
matemáticas su nombre es maribel nos da
el siguiente testimonio el logro más
significativo es que los estudiantes
tienen ahora más interés por aprender
matemáticas lo hacen ahora de una manera
significativa orientada a su vida real
parece es una excelente manera de
ejemplificar lo que puedes lograr con la
plataforma de khan academy
la parte teórica llevarlo a un plan real
en donde ellos pueden resolver los
problemas matemáticos de una manera
mucho más significativa al que le dé
sentido a su vida que le dé sentido
porque tengo que aprender aritmética
trigonometría geometría
pues es para resolver problemas
matemáticos de una manera mucho más
interactiva
de qué maneras puedes participar en esta
plataforma pues hay que celebrar
los triunfos de estos estudiantes es con
premios semanales medallas virtuales
certificados y pósters pasa la voz
comparte los materiales y recursos con
otros profesores padres de familia y
estudiantes en tu escuela o en tu
comunidad porque no de todo tu estado de
la república
y aquí viene mi parte favorita abrir un
dio de khan academy puedes organizar una
reunión en tu salón de clases durante el
recreo o al terminar tus clases para que
los estudiantes avancen en el campeonato
siempre hay 23 alumnos que están
entusiasmados motivados y que quieren
hacer más ejercicios pues no los límites
puedes crear un club y ahora sí darles
rienda suelta a toda su emoción su
motivación y estén enganchados y pueden
seguir los niveles que gusten y hacer
ejercicios extra y al mismo tiempo tú
les estás dando
una muy buena evaluación pero también
acá meca de mí les estará dando medallas
virtuales por esos logros o por esos
retos que ellos van cumpliendo
nos comenta victorias jiménez estudiar
matemáticas con la ayuda del cancán en
mí ya no es aburrido para los
estudiantes ojalá y nosotros cuando
éramos niños hoy hemos tenido la
oportunidad de contar con estas
plataformas pero bueno ahora los que
tienen la suerte y la oportunidad son
nuestros estudiantes en este siglo 21
nos manda saludos desde tlaxcala javier
juárez 48
nos comenta mariah de las dos rojas de
conalep de a calco el semestre anterior
celebramos a los estudiantes en el
evento de semestre de matemáticas se
organizó un curso de acuerdo a los
puntos logrados en khan academy
excelente idea excelente en manera de
poder enganchar a los alumnos de todo el
plantel
del coma leo felicidades maría de las
dos rojas por esa iniciativa desde aquí
te mando un fuerte aplauso por este
triunfo
para tener acceso a este reto de
campeonato lo único que tienes que
escribir
en la dirección electrónica de un
buscador como de google de escribir
campeonato punto canacar en el punto org
aquí está en esta diapositiva la
dirección electrónica y podrás
registrarte a partir de el 13 de agosto
y si todavía no tienes tu grupo
para el 13 de agosto lo puede registrar
una semana después dos semanas después
no hay ningún problema recuerden que
este reto dura 10 semanas entonces
tendrán tiempo suficiente para
registrarlo después
nos pregunta josé francos arredondo que
siempre tanto va a ser muy parecido al
ernest porque si es parecido nada más
que ahora está enfocado exclusivamente a
estudiantes de méxico y de habla hispana
sara martínez las preguntas que cuántas
clases tienen que crear
[Música]
las clases
que tú tengas si tienes cinco clases en
bachillerato con los profesores del
nivel bachillerato que llegará a tener
hasta diez grupos pues tendrías que
crear
10 clases y a cada clase darle su código
correspondiente
nos sigue comentando cada ocasión igual
participe del lean storm fue muy
divertido para los alumnos y les gustó a
la competencia excelente gracias por tu
comentario eso nos da una muy buena
retroalimentación y pues nos motiva a
que muchos profesores más enérgicos se
puedan integrar a este reto del
campeonato
me pregunta a magali hernández si tengo
alumnos asesorados de otras
instituciones nos pueden escribir claro
que sí
por supuesto magali hernández inclusive
puedes crear una escuela para tus hijos
para tus sobrinos para tus vecinos
realmente el límite es el cielo
nos pregunta de gómez para participar en
el campeonato es necesario dar de baja
las clases anteriores
no no
nos pregunta angelinas osa y las clases
pueden ser de diferentes materias
puede ser las matemáticas y ciencias nos
dice que para el siguiente semestre la
estadística pues puede ir
involucrar a sus estudiantes
a una muy buena pregunta de carlos era
fino el modo test como administrativo
puedo crear un grupo de alumnos para
competir por supuesto que sí
debes usar los grupos de sus clases
inclusive a este profesor que es
administrativo seguramente es y
deportarlos serafín le podría dar un mal
consejo crear una clase para profesores
puede hacer una competencia con los
mismos docentes de matemáticas
pero ese es un mal consejo
o un buen consejo depende la perspectiva
del director
nos comenta nos comenta martínez
nosotros los pusimos a competir entre
ellos en todos los granos excelente vida
excelente
ay creo que le gustó la idea a carlos al
fin olmos
y
ni conocer a un familiar que tiene
problemas para aprender matemáticas le
recomienda el uso de la plataforma y le
ha ayudado mucho mejorar sus habilidades
matemáticas excelente geo pineda muy
bien
gracias por tus comentarios
varicela solís de la cruz dice de su
fuertemente un 9 el vídeo que puedo
hacer para continuar con este programa
de capacitación puede encontrar las
ligas
que compartimos al inicio de esta
presentación y ahí están programas con
eso
le da seguimiento está muy bien
estructurado esencial para llevar a cabo
y no es ningún problema y en el peor de
los casos mandamos un correo a la
academy punto org y encantado de poder
apoyar
[Música]
nos dice gmc en de 62 ya creer mi gracia
añade a mis alumnos después del 15 de
agosto perfecto muy bien creo que sí
sergio esta arte me dice para que una
compañía pueda recomendar este chat que
tiene que hacer
compártelo
en la vida
para poder crear una cuenta de gmail y
acceder a nuestro canal de youtube
pues vamos a continuar con la agenda y
vamos a hablar un poquito de mentalidad
de crecimiento
los estudiantes se fortalecen con las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
entendiendo que el cerebro es un músculo
que necesita ejercitarse así como cuando
vas al gimnasio para ejercitar los
músculos de tus brazos de tus piernas
pues de la misma manera nosotros tenemos
que ejercitar nuestro
cerebro con habilidades de pensamiento
abstracto pensamiento matemático
esto le permitirá a los estudiantes
abordar los problemas matemáticos desde
diferentes perspectivas nosotros
hablamos de
cuando están ejercitando tu cerebro
tomar riesgos no tener miedo al fracaso
no tener miedo a los errores porque esos
mismos errores los convertimos en
oportunidades
el simple hecho de dar el primer paso y
darte cuenta que ese problema matemático
o esa nueva habilidad no te está
funcionando simple y sencillamente lo
vemos desde otra óptica es importante de
los errores como unas nuevas
oportunidades tenemos que superar la
frustración el miedo el estrés enfocar
lo que nosotros como docentes somos los
goles los perfectos roles
que el alumno debe seguir
por ejemplo aprendiendo algo nuevo cada
día aprendiendo una herramienta nueva a
lo largo de la semana
nosotros somos líderes
para ver hacia adelante no nos
frustramos en el pasado o en el error
que cometí sino convertir a ese error en
una oportunidad el camino es hacia
adelante hacia mejorar hacia crecer
aprender algo nuevo
y desarrollar una mentalidad de
crecimiento
imagínense que sus estudiantes puedan
dedicarle 20 minutos diarios a la
plataforma de scan academy sin duda
mejorarán su pensamiento matemático
podrás mejorar en asignaturas como
física química y por qué no programación
nos comenta una garcía que ya agregó una
plaza de una clase llamada campeonato
2018 excelentes felicidades
y recuerden una vez creada en esas
clases para el ciclo escolar pues son
los mismos que utilizarán cuando ya
tengan su lista de estudiantes
nos comentó dulce maría mónica monzón
rodríguez son del plantel iztapalapa del
conalep en la ciudad de mexico
bienvenida dulce maría
i
en el bordillo desde guanajuato
saludos
es importante recordarles que la
plataforma de khan academy se está
actualizando constantemente si pudiese
haber algún vídeo algún ejercicio con
algún problema
con alguna respuesta incorrecta podría
ser nuestros expertos expertos están
constantemente revisando la plataforma y
se va actualizando
los siguientes pasos
cuáles son los siguientes pasos
para continuar con esta plataforma de
khan academy pues si tienes a compañeros
que no pudieran asistir a este webinar
les puede decir que se registren al
programa de capacitación esta parte de
aquí que está subrayada con amarillo es
realidad para registrarse hacer todos
los que ustedes todos los que
participaron está esta tabla con
nosotros ya se registraron
el documento con la información del
programa es esta liga
esta segunda liga
recuerden que este programa dura 6 meses
para poder certificarse con los tres
módulos
vamos a ir añadiendo información clave
actualizando todos los temarios todos
esos artículos y videos
y el día de hoy pues continuar con los
pasos del módulo 1 y recibir tu primer
certificado
antes del primero de septiembre los
prácticamente tienen un mes para
para cumplir con estos requisitos como
ustedes saben
y ya crearon una cuenta de khan academy
aquí está la dirección electrónica para
que puedan compartir a otros docentes a
otros maestros
necesitan asistir por lo menos a dos
eventos en vivos
recuerden para tres o el primero de
agosto fue el primero
el 14 de agosto se llevará a cabo el
segundo evento
[Música]
posteriormente en octubre se llevará a
cabo el tercer webinar
hay que hacer la tarea
se estaba creando una tarea para que lo
pueden llevar a cabo y por supuesto de
suma importancia llenar el formulario de
registro que muchos llegan en el día de
hoy estos son los pasos a seguir si
quieren compartir la información con
otros docentes de su escuela de plantear
que suplanten si son directores si son
administrativos pueden llevar esto a su
plantel a su escuela para que todos
entren a este programa de capacitación
en el documento con información del
programa estaremos también compartiendo
las fechas
a través de correos electrónicos o
dentro del programa de capacitación
entonces no se preocupen por las fechas
solamente tengan en mente que habrá dos
webinars más
en las siguientes semanas
nos comenta david martínez
que haya utilizado la marca de mí para
analítica que es cuestión de buscar el
material y los temas que necesites
nos pregunta gerardo cacho como verifica
que asistieron a los webinars en el
momento que se registran nosotros les
damos seguimiento y no hay ningún
problema
dolores cambiarlos preguntas del
formulario es el que utilizaron para
registrarse
de todos modos aquí en el chat
están poniendo la información para ese
registro
y
eso
recuerden para tener acceso a la
plataforma de khan academy con el simple
hecho de escribir en tu buscador de
internet en ese punto
khan academy punto org tendrás acceso
a tu cuenta de khan academy para dudas
comentarios quejas felicitaciones para
cualquier soporte técnico puedes enviar
un correo electrónico un correo
electrónico a la arroba can academy
punto org y nosotros encantados de
apoyarte
en todo momento de una plataforma más
corriente de 24 7 24 horas
los siete días de la semana
me está preguntando de la tarea
van a recibir un correo electrónico
vamos a poner esa tarea en el documento
y todos podrán tener acceso
y llevarla a cabo
en el programa de capacitación allí
estará la tarea y ustedes podrán
realizarlas sin ningún problema
muchísimas gracias a todos los que nos
acompañaron esta tarde en este primer
webinar de khan academy totalmente en
español estamos agradecidos por su
presencia
cualquier duda mándanos un correo y
estaremos felices de poderlos ayudar que
tengan un excelente tarde
gracias
no
a 2
a